[Music]
El Presidente
to dinner yes
la soluta a appear the sitting is open
Lordan a village
the agenda covers the decoration of the
President of the European Commission on
the State of the Union before I give the
floor to president young curtly I'd like
to first of all thank and welcome and
also names the European Commission you
are here with him I want to give you
some information to do with the
organization of the debate today
yesterday I said that I considered this
Parliament to be the beating heart of
the European Union the very place where
the debate will take place on the future
of the European Union and I reminded us
of the importance of the speech that
will be given by mr. yoga today and I
invited all heads of state to come and
speak in this room and I think that we
are open to a debate on the future of
the Union because we are convinced that
this Parliament can make a determinative
contribution to the growth of the Union
the improvement of the Union to change
the thing that must be changed but also
to work together with the other
institutions in order to fulfill all of
the reforms that are required
institutional reforms those reforms that
look at actions against terrorism
against illegal migration and against
the exploitation of human beings but
also to work with the aim of creating
new jobs
which is a commitment from the
Commission an important commitment to
Industrial Policy which is something
which the European Parliament has indeed
underlined will be working side by side
with the Commission in order to solve
all of the problems which confront the
citizens that's why today we be
listening with such attention to the
suggestions coming forward from
president young it's going to be a deep
debate at the end of the debate
president Vianca
will make his observations and
thereafter the chair presence of the EP
will draw together this very important
morning with some thoughts so
immediately after president yonkers
presentation the chairs the group will
speak there will be a debate there will
be a reply from president Juncker and
then there will be conclusions drawn by
the presence of the group I would really
like to ask you all to stick to the
times that have been allocated because
this will allow everyone an opportunity
to speak and then also give president
Yonker a chance to give a recent
response to the issues that have been
brought out by the representatives who
are here in this Parliament thank you
once again and immediately I'll give the
floor to president yoga for the State of
the Union thank you
[Applause]
mr. president other members of the
European Parliament when I stood before
you this time last year I had a somewhat
easier speech to give
it was plain for all to see that our
union was not in a good state Europe was
battered and bruised by a year that
shocked our very foundation we only had
two choices either come together around
a positive European agenda or each with
it in to our own corners faced with this
choice I argued for unity I proposed a
positive agenda to help create as I said
last year a Europe that protects a
Europe that empowers Europe that defense
over the past 12 month the European
Parliament has helped in this agenda to
life we continue to make progress with
each passing day just last night you
worked to find an agreement on to a
different instrument and on doubling our
European investment capacity and he
succeeded thank you for that I also want
to thank the 27 leaders of our member
states this after my speech last year
they welcomed my agenda at the summit in
Bratislava in doing so they chose unity
they chose to rely around our common God
together result that you can deliver so
it's citizens when and where it matters
ever since we've been slowly but surely
gathering momentum it helped that the
economic outlook swung in our favor
we are now in the fifth year of an
economic recovery that really which is
very and every single member state
growth in European Union has outstripped
that of the United States over the last
two years it now stands above two
percent for the Union as a whole and at
two point two percent for the monetary
health unemployment is at a nine year
low almost eight million jobs have been
created during this mandate so far with
235 million people at work more people
are in employment in European Union than
ever before the European Union the
European Commission cannot take the
credit for this alone though I'm sure
that had eight million jobs been lost we
would have taken the blame but huge
institutions played their part in
helping the wind change we can take
credit for our European investment plan
which has triggered 225 billion worth of
investment so far it has granted loans
to over 450,000 small firms firms and
more than 270 infrastructure projects we
can take credit for the fact that thanks
to determined action European banks once
again have the capital firepower to
learn to companies so that they can grow
and create jobs
and we can take what for having bought
public deficits down from six point six
percent to one point six percent this is
thanks to an intelligent application of
the stability and growth pact we asked
for fiscal discipline but are careful
not to kill growth this is in fact
working very well across the Union
despite some criticism Tania's since
crisis truck
you economists finally bouncing back and
with our confidence our 27 leaders the
Parliament and Commission are putting
the tech in our union and together we
are putting the union back into our
union in the last year we saw all 27
leaders woke up to the Capitol Hill in
Rome one by one to renew their vows to
each other and to our union all of this
leads me to believe the wind is back in
your sights we have now a window of
opportunity but it will not stay open
forever let us make the most of the
momentum catch the wind in our sails for
this we must do two things first we
should stay the course at out last year
we have still 16 months in which real
progress can be made by parliament
council and Commission we must use this
time to finish what we started in
Bratislava and deliver on our own
positive agenda secondly we should
charge the direction for the future as
Mark Twain word
I'm quoting years from now we'll be more
disappointed by the things we did not do
done by those with it now is the time to
build a more united a stronger and more
democratic Europe put 4 2025 mr.
president president ladies and gentlemen
members of the Parliament why we look
towards the future we cannot lose our
direction together we have set ourselves
the objective of achieving an energy
union a security union a capital markets
union
a banking union and a digital single
market together we've all read as the
parliament has said the commission has
already presented 80% of the proposals
that were set out at the beginning of
the mandate we now have to work together
in order to ensure the D proposals
become legislative arts and that these
hats are made concrete in practice the
house is ever the case some concessions
will have to be made the proposals
afford by the Commission to reform our
common Asylum system or to set up new
solid rules on the posting of workers
are of course and I know this
controversial issues we will get good
results if everyone builds their part of
the bridge so that we can meet and I
would like to say that the Commission is
open to compromise starting from the
moment that the final result is good for
the Union and fair for all of its member
states we are now ready to submit the
remaining 20% of initiatives by May 2018
now this morning I spoke to the
president of the European Parliament I
unit a yani and the Prime Minister URI
rotters of Estonia and I sent a letter
of intention which sets out the
priorities for the upcoming year
I don't want and indeed I cannot here in
you read all of these proposals but do
allow me perhaps to mention five which
are particularly important first I would
like us to reinforce to strengthen our
European trade program Europe is opened
to trade yes but there has to be
reciprocity we have to get as much as
what we give
trade is not an abstract concept trade
it's jobs trade is new opportunities for
European businesses whether the large
scale or small every million in export
that we have equals 14 thousand extra
jobs in Europe trade is also exporting
our social and environmental norms and
our rules in terms of the protection of
data and food safety Europe has always
been an attractive economic space but
since last year I see that our partners
all over the world are knocking at our
door in order to sign trade agreements
with us thanks to the help of this
Parliament we've just concluded a trade
agreement with Canada which will be
provisionally applicable starting next
week we found a political agreement with
Japan on a new future economic
partnership and by the end of this year
we have a very good chance to achieve
the same with Mexico and the countries
of South America today we're suggesting
that we open trade negotiations with
Australia and with New Zealand I would
like all of these agreements to be
finalized by the end of our mandate and
I am absolutely committed to them being
negotiated in the greatest transparency
this opening to exchanges has to go
hand-in-hand with increased transparency
for our decision-making processes the
European Parliament will have the last
word corn all of these trade agreements
they're for its members just like
national and regional Parliament's have
to be kept absolutely up to speed and
informed started in the very first day
of negotiation and the Commission will
oversee this from now on and the
Commission will publish
all of the draft negotiation mandates
which it will present to the council the
citizen has the right to know what the
Commission is putting forward we have
finished with the lack of transparency
we're going to finish with rumors and
their ideas of intention that the
complaint that the Commission is very
often is being the subject off did you
mean for pool tips I'd like to say once
and for all that we are not naive
supporters of free exchange
Europe has always got to defend its
strategic interests this is why we
suggest today a new framework for the EU
on how we examine investments in English
is called investment screening if a
public business a foreign public
business wants to buy a strategic
European Ford part of our energy
infrastructure or one of our businesses
in for example defense technology that
can only happen in full transparency via
a deep examination and debate this is
our political responsibility to know
what is happening here in order to be
able if we need to protect our
collective security
didja molecule secondly the Commission
wants to make our industry stronger and
more competitive this is particularly
true for our industrial base and the 32
million workers who make up its backbone
they make the first-class products our
cars for example which explains where we
are ahead of others I am proud of our
car industry but I am shocked when
clients and consumers are intentionally
tricked Zavitz
I definite the automobile industry to
make proper amends for that and to
correct what they're doing rather than
trying to trick and to lead people into
error the car constructors ought to
invest in clean cars which are those of
the future
please don't only them EMS surely and
gentlemen we are going to present today
a new industrial strategy for Europe
which will allow industry to remain and
become the very first in the area of
innovation digitalization and
decarbonisation thirdly I want Europe to
be the vanguard of the fight against
climate change
last year we set a global climate norms
with the ratification of the Paris
agreement indeed in this very assembly
confronted by the reduction of the
ambitions which the United States has
shown Europe Europe is going to work to
ensure that the planet remains great and
it remains the indivisible a homeland of
all humanity the Commission will shortly
present a proposal to reduce the carbon
in the transport sector fourthly I want
us to protect better Europeans in the
digital area during the past few years
we have made progress in the
securitisation of the Internet there
have been new rules put forward by the
Commission which will protect our
intellectual property our cultural
diversity and our private personal data
we have strengthened the struggle
against terrorist propaganda and online
radicalization but Europe remains
pre-equipped confronted by cyberattacks
cyber attacks are sometimes more
dangerous for the stability of democracy
and economies than guns and tanks only
last year we have noted more than 4,000
attacks by cyberware and 80% of
Europeans enterprises have known at
least one incident linked to cyber
safety these cyber attacks
do not know borders and they spare
nobody this is why the Commission is
proposing today new tools and
particularly a European cyber security
agency to better defend us against these
attacks and fifth migration remains on
our radar even if the questions around
migration have often created debate and
pandemic we have managed to make real
progress on numerous fronts today we
protect the external frontiers in a more
efficient manner more than 1700 offices
of the new border guards and the coast
guards work with one of the thousand
national border cards in all the Member
States and work in Greece in Italy
Bulgarian Spain we have common borders
with the states who are not in the very
front line of the geographic situation
they must not be left alone for their
protection we have to have common
frontiers and common protection we have
managed to slow down the flows of
irregular migrants which is the source
of great worry in many countries we have
reduced the number of irregular arrivals
by 97% in the eastern Mediterranean
thanks to the agreement that we tree up
with Turkey and this summer we managed
to better control the central
Mediterranean routes the arrivals have
gone down by 81% in August compared to
the same month last year in this way we
have considerably reduced the number of
human lives lost Mediterranean
I can't talk about migration without
making a heartfelt homage to Italy for
its perseverance and its generosity son
darling what did in summer months the
Commission worked in harmony with the
Prime Minister my friend paolo gentiloni
and his government we did it will
continue to do it because in the
Mediterranean Italy is saving the honor
of Europe we have also under gently
improved the living conditions of the
refugees in Libya I upset by the
terrible inhuman conditions which we see
in the reception centres here Europe has
got a collective responsibility and the
Commission will work hand-in-hand with
the United Nations to bring to name this
scandalous situation which cannot
continue
mmm sous la Maltese even if it saddens
me that not all of our member states
show the same degree of solidarity
Europe as a whole has continued to shown
solid to show solidarity only last year
member states gave asylum to over 700
20,000 refugees or have foreseen how
they would be replaced the this three
times more than Australia Canada and the
United States together Europe contrary
to what is often said is not a fortress
and must never become one Europe is and
will remain the continent of solidarity
where you people have to be able to find
asylum if people are being accept are
being pursued for unacceptable reasons
just be Putnam and I'm particularly
proud of those young Europeans who are
volunteering to give language courses to
sue refugees or to all those young
people who by the thousands have joined
our new European solidarity corps these
young people give life and Colour to
European solidarity
Minda volatile defo but today we've got
to double our efforts before the end of
the monthly press the Commission will
present a new series of proposals
focused on returns solidarity of Africa
and the opening up of paths of legal
migration in particular come to the
issue of returns I won't repeat this
those who have no right to stay in
Europe I've got to go back to their
country of origin only 36% of migrants
in irregular situation are sent back it
is obvious that we have to considerably
strengthened our activities in this area
this is the only way that Europe will be
able to show proof of solidarity with
regard to the refugees who really need
protection
the Solidarity of the buzzards
solidarity cannot be an exclusively
entry European issue it's also about
putting in place greater solidarity with
Africa Africa cradle of humanity a noble
coordinate a young continent trust fund
for Africa which has been filled with
2.7 billion euros opened the
possibilities of jobs all over the
African continent but while the budget
of the EU is carrying the weight of the
financing the contribution of all of our
member states is only at 150 million
euros so the trust is now getting to its
limits we knew we have to know the risks
are there being a lack of financing in
2015 many migrants who wanted to get to
Europe when and because the food funds
of the UN ran out I'd ever want to
invite the Member States to join action
to words and to ensure that the trust
fund for Africa does not suffer the main
fate because the risk is great
News LOC travailler a Louisville we're
also going to work toward the opening of
legal migration routes irregular
migration will only stop when the
migrants have got another option than
undertaking a perilous journey today
answered Oliver we're on the point of
setting up 23,000 effigies coming from
Turkey Jordan and Lebanon and I am
actually supporting also the High
Commissioner than their students for the
reinstallation of 40,000 other refugees
from Libya and neighboring countries for
the rest Europe is a continent which is
getting older and this is another reason
for having a legal migration system
which is an absolute necessity this is
why the Commission has brought for
proposals to facilitate access for
migrants to the European blue card and I
want to thank the support of the
Parliament for this proposal didn't mr.
president ladies and gentlemen
vulnerable members I have just listed a
small number of initiatives that we have
that we want to complete by the end of
next year and we have to do that but
even that is not enough if we're to win
the hearts and minds of the people of
Europe the time has come to set the
course for the future in March the
Commission published its white paper on
the future of Europe with five different
scenarios setting out how Europe might
look in 2025 these scenarios were
debated sometimes superficially
sometimes in depth they were analyzed
and sometimes they were torn apart and
that is the way things should be because
that's what they were for
we have to set in train a process which
will allow the people of Europe
themselves to determine their future the
future of Europe is not something that
can be dictated from above any such
decision must be based on a broad
consensus in the wake of democratic
debate this house has made an active
contribution to this debate and I'd like
to thank all of the reporters concerned
I'd also like to thank those members
who've taken part in the more than 2,000
public stakeholder consultations which
the Commission has organized around
Europe since March the time has come
ladies and gentlemen to draw the first
conclusions from this debate the time
has come to take the next step from
reflection to action from debate to
decision
let me now set out the way I see things
you're about to hear my own my very
personal scenario number six this is
born out of decades of personal
experience I have lived the European
project through my entire life I have
fought for it I have worked for it I've
been through good times and I've been
through bad times I've sat on various
sides of the negotiating table as
Minister as Prime Minister as president
of the Eurogroup and now as president of
the European Commission I was there at
Maastricht at Amsterdam nice and Lisbon
where our union developed and expanded I
have always fought for Europe I have
sometimes suffered with Europe and
agonized over Europe I have been through
thick and thin
with the European Union and never have I
lost my love for the European Union as
we all know there is no love without
disappointment all very rarely love for
Europe I mean what I say because the
European Union has achieved so much in
this divided world inward and outward
peace prosperity not for all but still
for many in 2018 we should consider what
it means to have a European year of
cultural heritage and celebrate our
cultural diversity diverted Europe is a
Europe of values and a safe place for us
to be Europe is more than the single
market than money than the euro it's all
about values there are three fundamental
principles which underpin my scenario
number six freedom equality of
opportunity and the rule of law
first and foremost Europe is a union of
freedom and by that I mean freedom from
oppression and dictatorship those are
phenomena that our continent especially
its central and eastern parts have known
all too well and I mean the freedom
under flight and I mean the freedom to
speak our minds where there are citizens
or as journalists this is not to be
taken for granted and yet it is these
values of freedom upon which our union
is built freedom is not something handed
down to us we have to fight for it in
Europe and in the world was a new Europe
must be a union of equality and equality
of opportunity that means equality
between its members be they big be they
small be they in the East the West the
North or the South Europe stretches from
Vigo to Varna from Spain to Bulgaria or
what bombs Europe needs to breathe with
both its lungs the eastern lung and the
Western lung otherwise our continent
will suffocate in a union of equality
there cannot be second-class citizens it
is unacceptable that in 2017 children
are dying in Europe from diseases which
should have been eradicated long ago
Kindle children in Romania and children
in Italy should have the same access to
measles vaccines like children in other
European countries with no ifs and no
buts
yussle and that is why we are working
together with all of the Member States
to support their national vaccination
programmes there must not be avoidable
deaths in our Europe
yunano under glide in a Europe of
equality that cannot be second-class
workers people doing the same work in
the same place should receive the same
remuneration lism feel that is what is
behind the Commission's proposals on the
posting of workers we need to make sure
that all EU rules on worker mobility are
implemented fairly simply and
effectively and for that we need a new
european supervisory and implementation
authority it is absurd for us to have a
banking supervisory authority making
sure that banking zant standards are
respected when we don't have a common
labor market authority which makes sure
that the single market is built on
fairness the villages we are going to
set up such an authority in a union of
equality there can be no second-class
consumers I for one cannot accept that
people especially in Central and Eastern
Europe are buying poorer quality
products which have the same packaging
and the same label as those sold in
other countries a Slovak deserves to
have as much fish in fish fingers as
anyone else
a Hungarian should have as much meat in
meat dishes as anyone else and Czechs
should have as much cocoa in their
chocolate as anyone else that these this
these practices are already forbidden by
EU law and we have to make sure that
that EU law is enforced and we need to
ensure the national authorities have the
wherewithal to root out these practices
mr. in Europe law has muscle it's not
muscle that lays down the law and that
means that in Europe the law is
safeguarded by an independent judiciary
being part of a union which is built on
the rule of law means respecting court
judgments our member states have given
the European Court of Justice the powers
to take the ultimate decision and that
means ecj judgments have to be respected
in all cases failing to respect them and
undermining the national justice systems
means stealing citizens fundamental
rights in the European Union the rule of
law is not optional it's a duty our
union is not a state but it can be but
it's still governed by the rule of law
these are drug look these three
principles freedom equality of
opportunity and rule of law have to
remain the foundation of our ever
stronger and ever more United and more
democratic Union for the people of
Europe what they're looking for is not
new treaties new institutions there are
means to an end
new institutions new treaties are
perhaps of interest to us here in
Strasbourg or in Brussels elsewhere
people don't care two hoots I'm only
interested in institutional reform if it
gives if it gives us a more efficient
Union one day there will be treaty
change but to busy ourselves with the
now it means first and foremost that we
have to understand that democracy is
based on compromise not winners and
losers if we have the right compromises
everyone is a winner in the European
Union compromises are neither bad nor
ugly compromises are an art a way of
bridging differences and finding our way
to one another people who struggle with
compromises struggle with democracy and
struggle with Europe defconn if we are
to have a stronger European Union it
needs to be more inclusive - if we want
to bolster our external borders and
rightly so then it is high time to bring
Romania and Bulgaria into the Schengen
area
Daboo billion and incidentally croatia
to deserves full membership of the
Schengen area as soon as all of the
criteria are met if we want the euro to
unite our continent rather than dividing
it then it needs to be more than just
the currency of a select group of
country the euro is destined to be the
common currency of the entire European
Union all but two Member States are
duty-bound to join the euro area as soon
as they've met the conditions for that
to be possible
these Member States need the support of
a euro accession instrument which I
propose here today which will offer
pre-accession assistance in technical
and financial form if we want the
continents banks to operate by the same
rules and under the same supervision
then we should encourage all Member
States to accede to the banking union
that means we must reduce the remaining
risks in the banking systems of certain
Member States the banking union will
only work if risk reduction and risk
mitigation goes hand-in-hand for us to
be able to ensure that that is the case
a certain number of preconditions have
to be in place as proposed by the
Commission in November 2015 we can only
have a common Deposit Guarantee Scheme
when all of the Member States have done
their homework if we want to see an end
to social fragmentation and social
dumping in Europe the member states as
soon as possible and at the latest by
the Gothenburg summit in November should
agree on the European
of social rights national social
security systems are going to continue
to have their differences and will
continue to be separate but we should
still at least agree on a european union
of social standards to ensure that we
have a consensus about what is socially
fair and what isn't socially fair on our
single market blow it up on the website
damn it oh bugger linked a successful
Europe must not give workers the cold
shoulder ladies and gentlemen if we want
to have greater stability in our
neighbourhood then we need to offer a
credible enlargement prospect to the
countries of the Western Balkans during
the term of office of this commission
and this Parliament there will be no new
accessions because the conditions for
accession will not have been met however
in future the European Union will have
more than 27 member states in the case
of all accession countries the rule of
law justice and fundamental values have
top priority in the negotiations and
that rules out EU membership for Turkey
in the foreseeable future
[Applause]
for some considerable time turkey has
been moving away from the European Union
in leaps and bounds
journalists belong in editorial offices
amidst a heated debate and not in prison
vanilla hotel I appeal today to the
powers that be in Turkey let our
journalists go and not just our
journalists stop calling our Member
States and our heads of state and
government fascists and Nazis Europe is
a continent of mature democracies those
who knowingly offend pull up the
drawbridge and sometimes I have the
impression that there are those in
Turkey who want to pull up the
drawbridge and later blame the European
Union for the failure of accession
negotiations from our side there will
always be an outstretched hand
outstretched to the great people of
Turkey and all of those who are willing
to work with us
on the basis of our shared values calm
down and tell the ladies and gentlemen
honourable members I would like to see
our union stronger and that means it
needs a stronger single market in
matters of the single market we need
more frequent and simpler
decision-making on the basis of a
qualified majority with European
Parliament co-decision and that doesn't
need a doesn't necessitate treaty change
the existing treaties contain bridging
clauses which make it possible to decide
in Council on the basis of qualified
majority as long as this is decided in
advance by unanimity in the European
Council I'm thinking in terms of
decisions about value-added tax fair
taxation of the digital economy and the
financial transaction tax these
can all be decided by qualified majority
honestly
Europe needs to be able to take
decisions more rapidly and more
efficient more efficiently we need to
see a more agile economic and monetary
union the euro area is more resistant to
shocks than it was a few years ago we
have a European Stability Mechanism
which I believe should gradually be
turned into a European monetary fund
that needs to be anchored in the
European Union there will be specific
proposals coming from the Commission in
December of this year to that effect
we need a European Minister of Economy
and Finance a minister to promote
structural reform in our member states
the minister who can build on the work
done in the Commission by its special
unit two first structural reforms
support the European Minister of Economy
and finance should coordinate all EU
financing instruments and step in
whenever a member state is facing the
threat of recession or fundamental
crisis and here I'm not calling for a
new position for efficiency reasons I
believe that the future Commissioner
responsible for economic economy and
finance ideally a vice-president of the
European Commission carry out this role
the patient as well as chairing the Euro
group the European Minister of Economy
and finance must of course be
accountable to the European Parliament
we do not need parallel structures we do
not need a separate euro budget we need
a strong year
budget line within the existing EU
budget is calab that you do nor do I see
great merit in the idea of a separate
euro Parliament the Parliament of the
euro area is this one the European
Parliament the European Union also needs
to be stronger in how it fights
terrorism in the last three years a
great deal has already been done but
we're still not reacting so long and
slow quickly enough in the case of
cross-border terror threats I therefore
plead for the setting up of a European
investigating body that would make sure
that data on terrorists and foreign
fighters are automatically exchanged
between our intelligence and police
services I smile or jusht I also believe
that there are there is reason enough
for the newly set up European public
prosecutor to be responsible for the
prosecution of cross-border terrorist
crimes the European Union the European
Union should also have more influence on
the world stage
but it needs to be able to take its
foreign policy decisions more swiftly I
think it the time has come to take
foreign policy decisions in certain
cases by qualified majority and that is
allowed under the existing treaties as
long as there is a unanimous decision by
the European Council and there is reason
to do that it would make our work more
efficient in the field of defense more
efforts are required
the setting up of a European Defense
Fund is on our agenda permanent
structured cooperation in the defense
field is well underway by 2025 we will
need a functioning European defense
Union we need it and NATO would like us
to have it
the union should continue to do what the
Commission has thought to do lately ie
to concentrate on the important things
we shouldn't annoy the people of Europe
with nitpicking and nitty-gritty we need
to we need to act on the big things and
keep away from the small things which
can be dealt with by the member states
this commission has tried to play a
great role in the big things and to take
a back seat on the small things each
year it's put forward fewer than 25 new
initiatives remember the previous
commission was putting out more than a
hundred this month we're going to be
setting up a subsidiary and
proportionality task force the first
vice-president France Timmerman's has
already done a good job of better
lawmaking and he's going to lead the new
task force the Timmerman's task force
will have among its members members of
this Parliament and members of national
parliaments it will report in one year
which occasions on the president ladies
and gentlemen our union now needs to
affect a democratic leap I hope that
European political parties will kick off
their campaigns for the next elections
earlier than they did in the past
because all too often European electoral
campaigns have been reduced to a simple
totting up of national electoral
proposals and European democracy
deserves a lot more than that today the
Commission is setting out new rules on
the funding of parties and political
foundations it's not a question of
boosting the Treasuries of the
extremists that are against Europe it's
a question of allowing European parties
to better structure themselves
Jr I'm well aware that the idea is
contested by a number of people but I
have to say that I have quite a lot of
sympathy for the idea of having
transnational lists for European
elections and I will try and convince
the leader of my parliamentary group to
try and follow this idea because it will
lead to the more clarity and more
democracy for our elections I also think
that over the next few months we should
involve national parliaments and civil
society at the national regional and
local level we should involve them in
the work that we're doing on the future
of Europe over the last three years
members of the Commission visited
national parliaments more than 650 times
they participated in more than 300
meetings talking to citizens in more
than 80 cities in 27 member states
you
and that's why I support president
Mekons idea of organizing Democratic
conventions throughout Europe in 2018
you
as the debate develops
you
I will be attaching a great deal of
you
importance personally to Estonia Latvia
Lithuania and Romania in 2018 because
2018 is the year where these four
countries will be
you
elaborating their hundredth birthday
those who have the ambition to shape our
future and our continent need to know
about and honor our his
stry our joint history and so the
history of the four countries I
mentioned also is part and parcel of
that of course these are countries
without which Europe would not be
complete it is need to reinforce
democracy and transparency obviously
also has implications for the European
Commission today I am handing out to the
European Parliament a new code of
conduct for commissioners first and
foremost this code of conduct specifies
that commissioners can stand in European
elections under perfectly normal
conditions obviously the new code will
shore up the obligations of
Commissioners when it comes to integrity
during and after their mandate whoever
wants to boost European democracy could
never accept that the major democratic
progress inherent in the heads of list
system the schvitzing candidate
candidate and system would never go
along with that not being renewed
because it was an innovation and led to
more democracy and I'm convinced but I
buy that myself by the way will not be a
candidate but I'm convinced that the
future president will make the most of
this experience you can stand if you
like but you won't be elected
democratize more democracy that's what
we need and that means more efficiency
of course European efficiency wood wood
wood would be very much at an advantage
if we were to merge together the
presidency of the European Commission
and European Council that would lead to
a massive boost in efficiency this
proposal does not target in any way my
excellent friend Donald Tusk who I have
been working with very harmoniously for
over the last three years right from the
start of our mandate it is not this
proposed is not aimed at myself and it's
not aimed at Donald but all it does is
ensure that European landscape the
European landscape would be clearer and
more understandable if the European ship
was steered by one in the same captain
at the helm so if we just had a single
president it would better reflect the
true nature of our European Union which
is a union of states and a union of
citizens colleagues the vision of a more
unified Europe a stronger Europe a more
democratic Europe this is what I'm
presenting to you today and it involves
all the different scenarios that I set
out last March but our future cannot
remain a mere scenario some kind of
draft one idea among many others it's
today that we have to start preparing
our union of tomorrow this morning I
sent president Tye yani president tusk
and also to the future presences in
Council of the council from now until
March 2019 I sent them a road map
setting out the direction that we need
to follow and one important element in
this is the budget that the Commission
will be presenting in May 2018 there too
we have a choice to make here either we
ensure that the European ambitions the
European Union's ambitions are given a
command a budget commensurate to those
ambitions and that is something that I'm
very much in favor of we shouldn't be
making any cuts that would be the other
option which I would not be in favor of
March March 29th 2019 that were the date
whether you where the United Kingdom
will leave the European Union this will
be a very sad and tragic moment in our
history we will always regret this
but yeah and I think that you will
regret it as well soon if I might say
mainly Diwali nonetheless we have to
respect the will of the British people
but we are going to make progress we
will keep moving we will move on because
brexit isn't everything it's not the
future of Europe it's not the bill on
end or the 32 March 2019 on that date
will be a union of 27 and I suggest that
we prepare very well for that date the
European Parliament elections will will
have taken place just a few weeks later
in May 2000 and 19 that date will be a
very important meeting with European
democracy we need to ensure that
European citizens go to the ballot box
having a very clear vision of the way in
which the European Union will develop in
the years to come and that's why I am
calling on President tasks and on
Romania which will be which will have
the presidency during the first half of
the year 2019 I want them to organize a
special summit in Romania on the 30th of
March 2019 and I would like that summit
to be held in the Magnificent ancient
city of Sibiu which I also know under
the name of hair monster that would be
the right moment to take very important
decisions essential decisions in fact to
shape Europe a more united Europe a
stronger and more democratic Europe my
hope is that on the 30th of March 2019
Europeans will wake up in a union where
they know that we're defending their
values where all Member States
vigorously respect the rule of law where
being a member of full member of the
eurozone the banking Union and the
Schengen area have become a standard for
every member state of the European Union
we need to ensure that we defend our
single currency in all circumstances
good and bad without having recourse to
external aid single market needs to be
fairer for workers in the East and the
West
and I hope that they will wake up in a
world like that we also need to agree on
a bedrock of social standards where
profits are texts where they are
generated where terrorists find no fault
lines to exploit and where we will have
agreed on the creation of a true
European defence Union where a single
president will be at the helm of the
work of the Commission and the council
after having been elected in the wake of
a pan-european electoral campaign so yes
on the 30th of March 2019 our citizens
will wake up in that kind of union and
if that's the case they will need to
take part in the elections to vote and
they need to realize that our union is
working for them ladies and gentle
helmet call and Jacques dolor taught me
that Europe will only advance if it
shows courage the single market the
Schengen area the single currency all of
these things were projects when they
were first initiated or when they were
first thought of as mere flights of
fancy but all those projects that I
mentioned are a reality nowadays so
Europe is is faring better now and
people are telling me when one shouldn't
overload our European ship but at the
same time this stage that we have now
reached dictates that we shouldn't be
over cautious
it's not enough just to make minor
repairs what we should do today and
tomorrow is patiently step by step from
one inspiration to the next moving
onwards and complete not just the roof
of our European house but proceed in
building and completing all of the
floors of that house we need to finish
the job as a whole now the sun is
shining this is when we need to do it
because when the next storm brews and it
certainly will it will have been it will
be too late so let's raise anchor let's
get going let's set sail let's get going
and let's catch the wind in our sails
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
get out here
Thank You president of the Commission
thank you for your speech which now
gives us the opportunity to have an
important debate on the future of our
European Union you have given us in this
room very many elements for discussion
of great interest and we will listen now
to the words of the representatives of
the European citizens as president of
the Parliament all I can do is to share
your position on the need to have a more
democratic Europe I want to thank you
for having underlined this necessity I
share and I thank you again for a number
of the things that you sent more than
one thing that you said because you have
repeated the positions of the Parliament
on a number of key issues the fact that
the Parliament can also have it of
initiative this is something that we
want to count on the support of the
Commission in order to be able to launch
initiatives in areas of great importance
thank you now I will give the floor to
the chairs of the political groups the
first mr. Weber for the EPP mood here
requires courage
it requires optimism and creativity
we've heard that endure
yonkers speech I thank you very much for
this new start and I'd like to thank the
Commission as a whole for
the work that is done for our continent
trust colleagues can only be generated
through deeds the Paris climate
agreement theater better Border
Protection growth in Europe reduction of
unemployment well it's true that a lot
of people are faring better in Europe
today than in previous years and we are
delivering and when I say we I mean the
European Parliament which is the
people's chamber of Europe it is
something that we are delivering it's
only through our work that there is a
young Commission the first political
Commission is the child of this house of
this democracy in Europe and that's why
I think we can be proud of what we have
achieved together the Parliament and the
Commission are working together moving
in the same direction as far as the EPP
is concerned I welcome the ideas set out
by our president the president of the
Commission for deepening the European
Union the world is not resting on its
laurels it's not waiting for us we have
to make progress ourselves I as far as
the EPP is concerned we wants to take up
the cudgels
for Europe for people people are worried
about globalisation they're worried
about unemployment they're worried about
social dumping and we have the idea of a
social market safe job secure jobs a
decent wage a fair wage property if you
have property it means certain
obligations we need to be able to stand
up to the large players we are saying
yes to world trade but we want to
protect our core industries we want to
protect the social standards in the
European Union the European way of life
is a social one and I would like to see
us as the EPP in the center point of
that a lot of people are worried about
the the images that they see illegal
immigrants that arrive they don't
believe politicians anymore when they
say this is good for us
they are worried they were worried about
their culture they are worried about
their identity and that's why we need to
do all we can to protect our borders to
police our borders is not a case of
building up a wall around Europe but
illegal migration needs to be stopped
the European Way of life helps people
when they are in an emergency situation
when they need help but this doesn't
mean to say that we should be helping
people traffickers that we should be
helping illegal immigration integration
means as well that the values and the
traditions and cultures of our societies
are respected States should citizenship
in Europe should be linked to these
values anyone who does not subscribe to
those values should leave Europe another
concern that is expressed by people is
Turkey a lot of people are shocked when
they look at Turkey it seems that
arbitrarily people are being thrown into
prison it's change of the Constitution
the rule of law has been undermined
Turkey is moving away from Europe and
people don't understand why Europe isn't
doing anything we are a European
Parliament and we've made it clear that
we should suspend accession talks
because we want to send out a signal
that we cannot continue along these
lines in these circumstances and
jean-claude Juncker I think people are
worried and concerned that the
Commission in the parliament and the
European Union as a whole is not taking
sufficient action or speedy action
Barcelona Turku this summer many say
that Islam is a danger during the attack
on Charlie Hebdo in Paris two years ago
a French Polish man was executed by the
terrorists his name was Ahmed
Maribeth he was a Muslim who gave his
life to defend the freedom of
journalists dear friend it's not a
conflict between Christians
and Muslims it's a conflict between
humanity and paracin between values and
terrorism between our European way of
life and the madness of the terrorist
we must exchange our informations now
immediately entitle protection must not
be turned into protection of the
terrorists the European Way of life
protects the freedom of religion it does
not know the national egoism when
fighting together against the terrible
acts of the terrorists anti friends many
people as a last perspective from the
people's point of view are afraid when
they are looking east was in some days a
maneuver of Russian and Belarusian army
will start at the borders to our Baltic
States about 100,000 soldiers directly
at our border many people are afraid
after the wars in Georgia in Ukraine in
Syria what is put in planning now dear
friends a European way is to defend
ourselves and that's why the ideas of C
European defence Union are going in a
good direction we need them now your
friends we need them now and this is
also why we should stop North stream to
our security to your friends as priority
to making money and finally there are a
few of other perspectives from people's
point of view what they ask us to do and
we have to give proper answers let's act
now but to all these points I think it
says the need to have a to help to
combine them to bring them together and
that is from a vvp point of view to
define and to defend in the future the
European Way of life in the past our
founding fathers of the European Union
achieved peace say are they were
successful because they believed in
themselves today dear friends we must
defend the identity of Europe today we
to defend the European Way of life in
the world that is changing rapidly and
we will also be successful let's start
now thank you I know me
no in the name of the S&T group
mr. patella thank you president Juncker
that's true there is a wind of Hope a
new wind of hope blowing over Europe and
citizens are beginning to have the idea
that without Europe they'll be more on
their own unless defended but we don't
need to be idealistic about this we've
done well but we have only got one
bullet in the gun and we can't shoot it
wrong it is important that we ensure
that a lot of the ideas for Europe are
coming from our group the socialist
groups we say that we have to transform
the proposals and to results and as you
said let's be courageous with this let's
strike all the multinationals who have
defrauded the tax systems meaning that
they've actually and used their benefits
that should be going to the benefits of
the European citizen this has gone to
exploitation of young people
young people even those with masters end
up earning 550 euros a month this is a
scandal
there's the scant we have to oppose we
have to as the European commissioners
mr. Tim Owens is doing we have to look
at the issue of freedom equality the
rule of law democracy you said that
these are the pillars of the scenario
that you've painted I would say these
are the foundation this the very DNA of
the European idea
we have reinforced our decisional
process we have we ought to have a
European Minister of budgets but this
isn't just to be a kind of obscure
guardian of the treaties it has got to
be a democratic institution that
actually gives fiscal transparency I say
this clearly we do not want a minister
which actually becomes a kind of
policeman we want a minister which is
actually focused on growth and work we
have to get out of the rhetoric of the
three A's that had been talked about on
social welcome to the social world mr.
Weber I'd like to say welcome to the EPP
I look forward to you pushing behind us
as we have been pushing on these
dossiers over the years in the areas
other countries of the Commission we
have to have a child guarantee for young
men and women no child should be left
without education without home without
food this also plays unaccompanied
minors they have also got to be given
these things we have to be more
courageous when it comes to your
investment we have to be more critical
comes to fighting climate change there's
problems and wonderful work in that area
we have to ensure we can actually look
what's happening with hurricanes you
have to be able to foresee the disasters
Europe has got to be a leader in this
battle and now on immigration thank you
for recognizing Italy am I saying this
as a European not as an Italian but we
have to do more there has to be a
revision of the treaty and the Dublin
regulations but the socialist group will
not vote any decision without the
elimination of the ever get rid of the
country of the first safe country it has
to be legal ways of migration and the
blue card is an old tool we have to have
the courage to open legal routes for
migration that's the fair thing to do
but if we don't have these legal
migration channels were not going to
solve the problem and that's why we have
to have a partnership with Africa which
I would define as the partnership of
dignity you said there has to be money
yes it's very important that we ensure
that there is funds I think it's we need
to ask the young entrepreneurs who are
creating jobs and development in Africa
we have to have a proper a cohesion
policy we have to have a budget with its
own proper resources and we have to
think properly about the financial
transaction tax we have to president
Juncker we have to say yes to
transparency on the trade agreements
this is a we're defending this and the
interests of the citizen we have to go
over and above what's been done with a
chata
the soldiers want to go over and above
chatter when it comes to the protection
of the interests of the citizen on the
consumer
thank you for your patience but we have
got a white page and we can write this
white page together you talked about
innovation you talked about the huge
progress AI very often we talk about
this here
but very often it's like we're kind of
you know discussing amongst the Angels
by the world moves ahead without us what
we can do what we can't do it if God to
do we have to be part of this huge
transformation is taking place look at
the agenda 2030 for sustainable
development let us take that as an
example let's work with that with the
love that you have in your heart but
also the commitment that we have in the
socialist group to work together let's
ensure we do this with real with reality
and conviction I know may the group in
the name of the ICI our group the floor
now goes to mr. Kamath Thank You mr.
Yonko when it comes to jobs security and
freedom au protects cannot be a Europe
that is protectionist and the ECR group
believes that the EU needs to create
more opportunities not more regulations
and more agencies many of our citizens
tell us that they feel as if they have
little say in the decisions we make
about their lives their countries and
their futures when it comes to their
concerns over migration security and
jobs they prefer an EU that complements
their national and local governments not
seek to overrule them speaking as both a
future neighbor
you
no way that ever-hungry would leave the
union so I want to say in fact at the
occasion of this state of the union
jean-claude - mr. Hoffa - mrs. Lippman -
Victor Orbin welcome to the site of
reason even when we know all of us that
is not that have changed their mind it's
not by conviction that they're changed
and mind but by fear of losing votes
that they have changed their mind now
and the only way or the only one for the
moment we still doesn't get it I think
is Mr Farage he is still going up he
said last weekend he called the German
EFD to campaign on brexit I think it's a
fantastic advice to campaign on brexit
you have to keep up the good work Nigel
I hope they take it but unfortunately I
don't think that they are so stupid to
do that in Germany with the AFD and
because let's be honest it's clear what
our citizens want they don't want to
destroy Europe they want to reform
Europe but to destroy it no bloody way
that is the message of our mr. or
citizens and colleagues and that is what
I like so much in the State of the Union
this year by jean-claude Juncker let's
not make the mistake to take okay yeah
the war is over we have won a few
elections in a number of countries and
now the wind is blowing in the right
direction
now what the people want is not to
continue with this Europe they want to
reform to European you European Union
73% of our citizens want more European
action on the side of migration 75% want
more European action
you
as a safety net don't misunderstand me
because I gonna have my Irish friends
again me if I continue like that a
European border and coast guard and a
system of legal indeed gianni migration
so that people no longer die on also
because every dead body that we find in
the Mediterranean is a scandal for us
for Europe even one that in the military
a European defense Union so that it are
not the Americans and the Russians war
in fact deciding missus more gerenian or
backyard what is still the case today
a European FBI why because terrorists
are no borders that's the reality so why
we continue to do so and then also a
real government for the eurozone so that
we can steer the European economy and
that we can create what in fact we are
missing European champions guitar our
competitions rules war to narrow in fact
it is the fact that we have no unified
markets with single regulator's who make
that we have no European champions that
can become world champions and compete
on the world level but there is one
thing on which I have a little
difference of point of view were you and
it is on the institutional problem I'm
always thinking that good institutions
produce good policy and that bad
institutions create in fact still stand
stagnation and crisis and there are a
number of examples of that and that's
the reason why we in this Parliament and
I thank you for the support really
because that's very helpful that we want
also to create transnational list and a
real European constituency and why we
want to do that because it's time to
lift D D democracy to a continental
scale Europe dear colleagues is more
than the sum of 27 national democracies
we are more than that we are in fact a
democracy on a European scale also to
defend our values and our principles
outside the Union but
also inside the Union this European
democracy is necessary for example to
withstand outright governments like we
see today also inside in Poland and
Hungary would think in fact the Trump
which is white supremacy is the example
or put in an urban would jail opponents
is the example well that will never be
the example in whatever Member State
in European Union and for that reason we
have to create this European democracy
with a transnational in fact
responsibility because we need as
Emmanuel macron has said it nearly to
the Acropolis because we need to be the
counterweight of all these developments
and autocratic leaders worldwide a
beacon of openness a beacon of freedom
and a beacon of hope in the 21st century
thank you present and thank you
jean-claude juncker for the state of
view
they're a group thank you know for the
gooey ng L the floor Nyko is 2mr yike
um Monsieur de could mr. president
President of the European Commission you
have painted a canvas which does not
represent what the people of the
European Union are living through you
cannot paint a canvas so made up of
Statistics
I'm afraid the workers who are who see
their jobs are under threat the small
farmers who see themselves being priced
out of the market the unemployed for
whom nothing is being done these people
see a different picture and however many
billions you place upon the altar what
can we actually say we have achieved
when people can't make ends meet that's
the crisis in the European Union the
crisis that sweeping through the
European Union because we are not
listening to the people we don't have
the necessary social and environmental
idealism the Antilles Cuba and bits of
the United States have suffered from a
terrible storm we need to fight climate
change the trade deal with Canada the
flies in the face of what was agreed in
Paris Europe needs to see social
progress environmental progress in
transport energy housing urban
renovation and farming we need to change
the systems of production that would
create thousands of jobs in Europe
and it would allow new training and
research opportunities all of that is
possible not by setting up a European
Monetary Fund but by turning the Yunker
fund into a real social and
environmental development fund which
through the ECB would write off the
debts of the Member States and kickstart
new projects to protect the lives and
ambitions of all Europeans all that the
Greek government wants is for training
programs for unemployed Greek people to
be funded from the Yunker plans Europe
needs to stop being focused on
competition asocial Europe with a
minimum wage doing away with precarious
work going back to job security proper
pensions eradicating poverty sharing
wealth fairly justice for posted workers
equality between men and women more
rights for people to take decisions in
their companies tax harmonisation
fighting tax fraud and tax havens that's
what we need to be doing enough of this
nauseating discussion of the refugee
crisis let's have a proper Europe of
solidarity let's have a development pact
with Africa and let's root out violence
and war from the Middle East it is high
time to listen to the people
democracy is knocking at the door it's
time to listen and let it in
[Music]
what we need is a democratic social and
environmental renewal to take place in
Europe starting from the grassroots the
European Union should also help to
reduce conflict it should be in the
vanguard of nuclear disarmament and the
European Union should certainly not beat
a path of militarization as is being
proposed it ought to be promoting
education and culture instead we want to
debate mr. president we want a real
debate which will turn the European
Union into a force of social progress
environmental progress and peace
embedded in democracy very group for now
for the green group the floor goes to
Muslim birth Gingka thank you very much
president mr. Juncker we listen to you
very attentively and I'm trying to put
myself in the shoes of all my citizens
all our citizens that cannot go on like
this anymore that can't make ends meet
that are victims of the situation today
that don't aren't covered by Social
Security whereas the richest among our
society get away scot-free so there
there's a lot of problems here they
can't they're not they don't get jobs
often there's more flexibility that is
set out but it's actually more
flexibility more protection for the
people that hold the capital here and
also the fight against terrorism this is
something that needs to be tackled much
more they can't go on as as the stands
people are just suffering too much today
a lot of the time citizens attribute to
Europe this scourge that they can't
tolerate anymore we do have a lot of
responsibilities to bear but a lot of
the time the Commission too often
doesn't do enough of course we can
congratulate ourselves be very pleased
that lepen and wielder and the like
don't carry sway anymore but a lot of
citizens aren't really seeing the
benefit of that also the also
nationalistic ideas are also happening
within your political family mr. Yong
chol look at Austria so often this is
called the Commission the last chance
Commission but I think there's more to
it than that you need to ensure that
European integration you're trying to
tell citizens that European integration
is in their favor sometimes they don't
understand that message a lot of the
things that you have said are music to
our ears the eurozone proposals this
idea of transnational lists it's
something that we of course go along
with we've been pleading for that for
decades now but everything that you're
suggesting here today is hopefully going
to give us a jolt now that's what we're
hoping for other things that you could
have said today but citizens you might
be legitimately asking yourselves
whether your democracy is actually
working in your favor
well what we need to do is ensure that
we reduce inequalities and ensure that
our ecological pact is being added to
our objective is to give everybody the
possibility of a dignified life how are
we going to achieve that well I am
committed to ensuring that all
legislation all actions all
recommendations coming from my committee
will be screened for these things in
reducing inequalities making sure that
the ecological balance is stacked is
stuck to this kind of thing our
committee my committee will not
we'll ensure that there is cooperation
from the bottom upwards we will ensure
that we realign our trade policies it's
got to condition the access to our
markets respecting social stands as
environmental stands as our healthcare
standards that we have chosen also we
will freeze SATA the application of Sita
and revise the recommendations for all
the trade agreements in the offing at
the moment the internal market that
needs to be reworked
we are completely determined on this we
will be deleting glyphosate we will be
wanting to remove glyphosate and also
endocrine disruptors that is something
that we are going to look at very
carefully Europe should be the tool with
which we construct our European future
the only opportunity for Europeans
finding their place in a work world
economy is to ensure that they are at
the vanguard of developments that will
help sustainability on our planet
so rather than defending the current
order our committee my committee will be
supporting anything that goes in that
direction towards that transition we
want a Europe in which nobody feels left
in the cold we need to assume our
responsibilities also these are the
people that are banging on the door
asking for our help we need a more
democratic society the democracy has
been harmed when justice isn't a dared
to and when the universities and media
are undermined
there needs to be very tight checks on
this governments need to ensure that
everybody is dealt with in the same way
it shouldn't be giving succor to the
major players that contain all the
capital in their hands no democracy is
not something that is irreversible we
need to ensure and you have said that
yourself we are the guarantees of the
rule of law we need to ensure that
continues to be the case European Union
is very rich a lot richer and then it
was 60 years ago it's more wealthy in
all kinds of ways but the only way in
which we can take control of our future
is to do this together
mr. Younker by implementing this kind of
agenda I think you will have really
grasps your final chance I think you are
somebody that will have put Europe back
on track again rather than being someone
associated with other less favorable
associations and now for the EFT the
first mr. Faraj mr. young that was the
most open honest and truly worrying
speech I've heard in my long years in
this place the message is very clear
brexit has happened full steam ahead
so new plans this to be one powerful
president for the whole of the European
Union a finance minister with fresh
powers to as you say yourself intervene
as when he sees necessary a stronger
European army in the militarized
European Union with a stronger and
perhaps more aggressive foreign policy -
and more Europe in every single
direction and all
of it to be done without the consent of
the people your plan to fight the next
European elections with cross European
pan-european lists funded by the
European Union but not as you said to
fund extremists means what we will find
is genuine democratic parties of
opposition will not be able to compete
in elections on the same playing field
it is reminiscent of regimes of old
indeed the way you're treating hungary
and poland already must remind them of
living under the soviet communists when
you attempt to tell them how they should
run their own countries all I can say is
thank God we're leaving but you've
learnt you've learned nothing from
brexit if you'd given Cameron
concessions particularly on immigration
the brexit vote I have to admit would
never ever have happened and yet the
less than you take is you're gonna
centralize you're gonna move on to this
new I think very worrying undemocratic
Union and you're deluding yourself mr.
behalf step if you think that the
populist wave as you define it is over
if these plans of mr. Yonkers come to
fruition far from the populist wave
being over by doubt it's even begun
they're a group up there Robin and now
for the NF group the to the forego
streams to the Lim ski Thank You chair
ladies and gentlemen we have to say
these are apologists for European
centralism European Union is not Europe
and Europe is not the European Union the
European Union has nothing more than
less than an association an association
with certain rules and you can change
these rules and to change the directions
well we don't agree with it I don't
think you are allowed to make those
decisions it's the people it's the
citizen in the free voting system who
are able to make decisions about the
direction and that's the thing and what
mr. yoga said today goes exactly against
that what your car was the factor is to
force the European Union into a single
state and we know that the euro is not a
success story we extraordinary debts
we've seen the astonishing unemployment
we've seen the astonishing negative
social impact on people's lives we see
this incredible social instability
the second thing mr. Janka wants is de
facto to actually get rid of the all the
internal borders we see ten thousands
hundred thousands millions of Africans
and Arabs are going to be coming to our
continent everything's good to be there
including terrorists and we know that
the people who committed the terrorist
attacks came through these routes into
Europe and that is a threat to security
for all citizens of our continent
they're talking about having a defense
defense Union but no we don't want that
what we want as a Austrians we want
we're neutral country in Austria what we
do not want to participate in the
defense Union the right road for Europe
can only be the road where there is more
democracy left to the people more
democracy left to the citizen where
people can vote whether or not the
have Shingen maintained or not if they
want to have their borders or not their
votes got to be left to the citizen
ality of having free movement at a
moment of of terrible unemployment it's
the citizen has got to say whether or
not they want that to be in place that
is what we need in Europe democracy
pluralism you have to give more
sovereignty back to the States
if you have ever gone to function it
doesn't work now and you know it
yourself it would be good if we changed
it to act Oakland scenario pop wouldn't
the sixth scenario we heard for the
future of the European Union is yet
another attempt to find a compromise
between the Harz competition that is
going on within the EU and the eurozone
were Germany has sprung far ahead from
the other countries at the same time in
all countries all the governments are
pulling pushing ahead with very harsh
measures against the workers in Greece
in France in Italy they're relieving big
businesses from taxes you said some
words about the EU becoming more
powerful it only means that the EU is in
class against the United States Japan
and China we cannot hide the fact that
despite your talk about peace the EU is
actively taking part in imperialist wars
the EU is only becoming worse and the
people's discontent is growing every day
we need to overthrow the real enemy
Aurra I normally now in the name of the
council masika's thank you very much
miss president speaking not behalf of
the council the council cannot have a
position on this on this speech and
speaking on behalf of the of the
Estonian presidency of the council I
thank President Juncker for his
ambitious clear and most importantly a
thoughtful speech in this moment who
would wind in our sails we should bear
in mind a couple of lessons in that in
that last couple of years have taught us
first to do we who care for our union
must have the courage to make the
positive case for you it's not it's not
only a right thing to do but it also may
pay off in elections secondly we should
not be afraid of speaking of the cost of
non-eu of the consequences of so far
thank god only hypothetical rolling back
some advantages of European integration
thirdly we must keep looking for issues
initiatives in ways that unite us and
not those that pose risk of dividing
Member States we should look for
initiatives that balance things and
build bridges for instance it is much
easier to talk about the EU social
pillar something that the Estonian
presidency will duly take forward when
we simultaneously take real steps in
deepening the single market in
particular in the field of services so
not only better paid jobs but also
better access to these jobs fourthly of
course we must keep developing the EU
further but doing this we must not
forget that this time around in 2017 it
is not the institutional set up that is
most important it is important of course
but reshaping the institutions must go
hand in hand with provide
in concrete benefits concrete things for
our citizens our citizens must be at the
center of our attention delivering
concrete benefits for the citizens
that's what the guiding principle of the
Estonian presidency is ladies and
gentlemen for the last several years we
have all been working on building a
digital single market the free movement
of data is one of its cornerstones we
need to ensure that European citizens
and businesses are able to benefit from
data and that we create no new barriers
to the single market as with the --use
other freedoms free movement does not
mean a freedom from rules next year new
EU personal data protection rules come
into force and we look forward to
starting work on the Commission's new
proposal on the free flow of data Thank
You president Juncker
for this proposal member states have
repeatedly emphasized that legislation
in this area is necessary
the Estonian presidency will move now
swiftly attempting to consolidate member
states positions on the concrete
proposal as we grow Europe's data
economy and enter the era of the
Internet of Things cybersecurity becomes
a matter for everyone we welcome the
renewal of the EU cybersecurity strategy
proposed by the Commission cybersecurity
is a challenge that cannot be tackled by
any member state on the road we all need
to fulfill our responsibilities by fully
implementing the existing EU legislation
must deploy all parts of our toolbox
working on the new legislation working
engaging with the private sector the EU
also has an important role to play
setting international norms pursuing
cyber criminals standing up for European
values such as freedom and privacy
guiding the development of the global
market for secure products and services
and reacting to states that sponsor and
support malicious cyber activity the
heads of state and government will
address these key
at the Talon digital summit 29th of
September ladies and gentlemen i earlier
listed some recent lessons for the EU we
have also learned that while
strengthening the EU internally is of
course key for the health and
functioning of the Union itself at the
same time to be and to appear strong the
EU also needs to remain engaged and open
to the outside world we are a model to a
number of countries in our neighborhood
and we should not forget it the EU s
transformative power is still very much
there the Eastern Partnership summit in
November is an opportunity to reconfirm
our commitment to our neighbors positive
transformation in the field of trade the
EU must perform a tough balancing act
president Juncker laid out very
eloquently the elements of it we of
course welcome the message that we can
now proceed with the free trade
agreements with Australia in New Zealand
and to expand the network of liberal
trade relations in this globalized world
the Commission has gone a long path with
its reflection paper on harnessing
globalization and deserves to be
commended for that with regard to the
proposals about investments and the
multilateral investment court as
presidency we will make our best efforts
to proceed in the best possible way to
build the consensus among the Member
States in a manner that will enable the
EU to continue its leading role in trade
policy and now to migration the crisis
of which shook the fundamentals of the
EU and showed that the EU does not
really have a headquarters to manage an
acute operational crisis d EU doesn't
have a general if you will this is not
to say that we haven't had achieved a
lot in the field of migration the work
on the external dimension is ongoing
well and maybe for the first time the
Union is using all the tools in its
foreign policy toolbox at the same time
assistant develop
meant trade military operation in
lodgement police even the Estonian
presidency is working hard on migration
issues not least while carrying forward
work with a common Asylum assist on
legal migration we eagerly eagerly
started working with the European
Parliament on the blue card directive on
security we are ready to engage with the
Parliament on ATS and hopefully on these
initiatives and of course we are
confident that an inclusive and
ambitious permanent structured
cooperation in the field of defence can
be lodged launched by the end of this
year ladies and gentlemen the speech by
President Lincoln and the debate we have
had so far shows us once more that in
our in our in our union there is much
more of what unites us than what creates
tensions Estonia a country that was
deprived of the advantages of the
European integration during its first 40
years feels that particularly deeply
that is the compass while we act as a
Member State that is our compass
especially while we are performing the
duties of the presidency of the Council
of the EU with the wind in our sails
thank you
at least the Dimpy now because of the
time restraints were not going to have
any blue cards here the focus mr. Casper
e-cigarette president mr. president one
or two years ago the mood here was
somber Commission president young had
talked about a window of opportunity and
we should seize that opportunity
Manfred Weber talked about people's or
worries worries for instance about
globalization give us some weeks to talk
to these citizens what we need to see is
quick transparent negotiations with
Australia and New Zealand we need to
protect we need to reform our trade
protection instruments and an instrument
again tech against external strategic
investment because we need to be able to
protect our industrial base secondly
people are worried about jobs not least
Germans about jobs in the car industry
there's a crisis of trust but we also as
we take climate action we need to
protect jobs because we need climate
protection we need cars and we need jobs
we don't we can't have one and lose the
others and this is what has to permeate
our legislative proposals in the coming
months and on the transnational lists
many people think that we're in an ivory
tower here in Europe we need to bridge
the gap we need to we need to be closer
to the citizens pan-european lists in my
view will set us further apart from
citizens and therefore we reject them
rodriguez rodriguez welcome mr.
president
this is a moment for us as a last shot
to have a real vision and ambition what
is at stake for this legislature it is
indeed to develop the European house and
to move to the next stage a new floor is
to make Europe not only as a single
market or a eurozone but also as a
political entity able to respond to the
new world in front of us we need to
repeal Union as a big democratic power
supporting our way of life and making
sure that we have the means to deliver
our values and our way of life
this means indeed to have new means for
peace and security to manage migration
and to support development but for this
we do need a new brand new community
budget for the future based on new own
resources turned to the future not
the past and this means when it comes on
resources that big corporations should
pay their taxes because they must
benefit from the single market but pay
what they do to pay then if we have in
mind a new democratic political entity
these can only be based on stronger
european citizenship
first of all respecting fully the
fundamental political rights of our
citizens but also making sure that we
can count on updated social standards
when it comes access to social
protection when it comes access to
skills but also making sure that
everybody in employment whatever the
kind of jobs they have they can count on
the decent labour contracts and this
access to social protection these should
be the ambition of the upcoming European
social pillar but can we say that these
Europe as land of equal opportunity of
fairness is being delivered to all
European citizens we don't think so
Europe is still working as a machinery
for diversions and inequality and we
need to reverse this way undermining
trend so we call upon the Commission to
come up with an ambitious proposal of
community European budget turning
European project a project for equality
and conversions and this should apply
for the European Union as a whole and
also for DeRose own so this is our
request for the upcoming their work
coming from European Commission
the prego the respect re asking people
to please stick to the time that's been
given to you because otherwise we will
end up cutting time from other MVPs who
wish to but has bitten catch the eye the
floor now goes to mr. Lucca
hey mr. younger you had 60 minutes to
build illusions castles in the air'
you've awakened illusions that really
have no realistic basis that don't
really tackle the problems that the
European Union is facing you talked
about the reality of the European Union
and you talked about fish fingers
vaccinations cocoa content of chocolate
but what about the major problems that
need to be tackled in the European Union
you haven't offered any solutions you
talked about the law of the role of law
but you didn't talk about the breach of
the Maastricht Treaty that the fiscal
pact has been infringed several times
the double impact that all of these
things have been violated that monetary
estate funding is still being carried
out these illusions you are giving
succor to them to 120 billion euros that
have been generated but the banks are
saying there's not actually any project
that we wouldn't have funded anyway so
you're not addressing Europe's real
problems and the European Union will not
get out of the crisis in this manner
Latika thank you president not bad in
fact not bad at all I think that this is
something that I can very well work with
on the Czech domestic political scene
we are spoken about to your life having
been a fighter of course me on a
different level I've been going through
a similar experience in the Czech
Republic and I think that with this
vision with these ideas I mean I'm happy
to confront some of your former
counterparts politicians that have use
of the first half of 20th century so
thanks for that
even though of course some disagreements
say for sure but that is absolutely
normal
let's forget the five scenarios I think
that we
we both know that three of them were no
scenarios at all and I think that if we
have now the priority agenda I will have
wished maybe that you have shortlisted
to three more but I understand that we
will find them in in the report but I
think that the implementation of these
priorities the reform agenda that you
have put emphasis on and that I
subscribe to will lead us to the outcome
and that is the sixth scenario so the
European Union that we want to have
maybe someone will fall behind but very
of course remains to be seen finally
mark unity I I believe as you do that we
are in a better shape but if we have
still a problem that is lack of unity in
the council lack of ability of the
Member States to deliver on what they
have even proclaimed themselves before
one final remark president unkar not
offended that you have forgotten the
Czech Republic as a country that will
also be 100 years old nest next year no
offense thank you
Thank You chair I must admit I find it
arrogant mr. president that you say that
things are going in the right direction
because that's not the view of our
citizens they see poverty they see
deterioration of their welfare they see
their salaries under pressure they see
high on unemployment particularly youth
unemployment and they see an EU that
doesn't solve their problems but makes
their problems worse they see an EU that
does not listen to them but instead of
looking at the real problems you sit
there with the rest of the EU elite in
your glass tower saying you want more EU
more power to the EU Commission a
finance minister to control the Member
States even more in the direction of the
Commission a president or for all
presidents to make sure we have one
union with one president I find it
arrogant towards our citizens and
towards our democracy and honestly I
think that this Commission has plenty of
powers already never allah-allah know
the florida sanitary cameras
president Keanu's to Bianca I'm going to
talk to you today in Spanish
surprisingly you didn't mention the
situation in Spain with the upcoming
Catalonian referendum because hundreds
and thousands of cutter lands have been
asking for a referendum on
auto-determination
just like the Scottish the Spanish
government never wants to speak about
this I hear about it
the Catalan the government has approved
by majority the law of the referendum as
if it were in fact a crime to have
referendum a court case has been brought
against the president of the Catalan
Parliament and also against over over a
thousand local civil servants who are
working in favor
if of the referendum these are
unacceptable attacks on
you
ramani they protect new some mrs.
contempt for the
MVP's but also for the heads of state
and government of hungary poland and
slovakia who stand up against your ideas
Masuka you said a moment ago that Europe
is a an ageing continent you said you
wanted to set up some new roads for
extra European immigration even though
that in fact is what caused a profound
identity security economic and social
disorders that were dealing with you try
to actually distinguish legal
immigration which you want to encourage
from to understand immigration which you
want to fight without ever giving
yourselves the resources now these two
kinds of immigration don't cause each
other they accumulate we have to give
hope and confidence that people of
Europe we have to get our own
demographic the dynamism you have to
give them the mastery of their own
destiny and build a Europe which is
built on cooperation that's our vision
that's against your vision use the
simplest rigid and totalitarian laugh at
all and now the floor goes to mr.
Sonnenberg president and president
colleagues probably more presidents here
than colleagues at the moment but never
never mind in the last three years as an
MEP I have achieved a great deal of work
I sent away the Brits I D throned mr.
Schulz and I also ensured that Helmut
call was we moved somewhere else and
also there's the Polish pis party I've
tried to teach them democratic values
and I'm particularly proud that the EU
has taken onboard an original idea that
we had normally a wall a wall around
Europe just recently going along with
the CSU we asked for an upper limit of
for refugees Germany shouldn't take in
more every year than the Mediterranean
ocean now the Mediterranean
Mediterranean ocean is is full so the
idea is to construct a wall around those
failed States Chad and Molly
I would like to say sorry to very to
foreigners here because a lot of
decisions were deferred until after the
elections in Germany just another week
and then the party will start governing
again mr. Weber you have a point of
order
segata fell president in via cíntia
Parliament Madam President this is a
parliament where we have freedom of
speech and everybody is entitled to say
what they want however to speak of the
deceased as mr. Sano born just has in
the case of Helmut Kohl that is a matter
for the Bureau to deal with it is
completely undignified and unacceptable
Thank You mr. Weber we will look into
that matter I now give the floor for one
and a half minutes to mr. levin dosti
jaquail thank you there's a different
climate in Europe now we had a very
different state of the Union speech in
2017 this was not technocratic optimism
last year we were shocked by the UK
referendum we thought that there would
be a rising tide of populism instead of
shock though now we have shock therapy
and it's not Europe that's in the shadow
of brexit it's the United Kingdom the
greater creation of the founding fathers
is going to continue to flourish
we have scenario number six this is good
news there are some exceptions to the
good news though my country Poland is
also going to be celebrating a hundred
years of regaining independence my
country Poland is inhabited by people
who feel good in Europe and about Europe
they feel themselves at home in Europe
I'd like to say on behalf of my
delegation the
we'll do everything we can to ensure
that Poland will be a full participant
in the quest for a new European unity
thank you thank you madam phione one
minute please
pile up a little duo time special
anybody see me queuing courtesy to guys
Thank You president I would like to
congratulate you on your speech
president Yunker rule of law young
people and the Western Balkan area these
three things are very much close to my
heart you talked about the rule of law
and you said that court judges should be
enforced you talked about you know
countries shouldn't be able to decide
themselves which judgments they enforce
or carry out or not what about some
countries that aren't doing this you
need to look at that mr. Janka and then
how do young people get any faith in the
European Union they see politicians not
really responding to their problems they
are unemployed they don't get jobs and
the Western Balkan Harry there are
problems you said you wanted a credible
enlargement policy but that's not
happening because it's a playground for
geopolitical interests we're going to
have second-class citizens if we're not
careful we need to invest in Europe that
is not a continent of intolerance hate
and walls my biggest wish is to ensure
that we can breathe fully thank you mr.
Orban Crespo hey Senor Diaz Lackey C's
ladies and gentlemen the crisis in
Europe started in 2002 net mr. young Co
you will finish your job in 2019 and
this in fact will be seen history as a
lost decade it'll be a decade of
austerity in Europe European Union is
not in fact moving forward it's not a
problem of speed it's actually a problem
of political well with your speech you
insist on continuing on the same
road that has brought us to this
situation
it's a Federalists division what you're
doing is you are creating an
anti-democratic machine which in fact
leads to blackmail financial blackmail
in order to impose a neoliberal vision
not as already proved it doesn't work
and which ends up falling in the
shoulders of the European population the
problems in Europe are going to be
solved by new trade associations more
externalization of our borders isn't
going to help more budgets for defense
isn't going to help this is going to
lead to more austerity because these are
responding to the interests of
multinationals lobbies and government
what we need is a change of direction we
want 180 degree change of the external
policy ecological policy of a metal
policy and social policy that's we have
to do we have to work from the ground up
this would be a real change I'm
following the instructions of the
president who really asked us to respect
our speaking time one minute now for mr.
Vallee please see Grazia president thank
you very much madam president mr. Uecker
touched on very important topics
security immigration economic mass
aspects I'd like to focus on economic
aspects the European Stability Mechanism
and front turning that into a European
fund it's something that's quite
difficult to understand for some people
I think it's quite easy particularly
with regard to what the European finance
minister has suggested namely a
structure namely the troika it would
mean that Member States would give money
to the to the ESM and would receive in
revenue against that they would receive
reforms that's the idea that as a
counter they would receive restore
reforms but I'm not sure that will
really work there's the quantitative
easing idea
that has also been put forward but we've
got Germany that isn't assuming its
responsibilities it's not accepting true
euro bonds or fiscal transfers so it's
only structural in democratic that will
continue to support intolerance and
sufferance and this is completely
unacceptable
thank you mrs. Atkinson one minute
pleased that you think everything in the
EU garden is rosy there's no mention of
the 50,000 jihad is waiting to blow us
up that are going through your failed
immigration policies no mention of your
failed immigration policies and the
marauding migrants breaking into our
countries at least the European Eastern
European countries have got the right
idea no mention of your failed youth
employment schemes but there is good
news in the UK we have record employment
despite brexit we've got record inward
investment despite rate set volume of
output is the highest in 20 years
despite brexit and Bill Gates said that
despite breaks that Britain still can
lead in the science and tech nology
institutes and our older books are the
highest in 30 years
despite brexit the City of London is
still number one
despite rec set so sorry to invade your
space mr. Younker but you and the EU and
your ideas are really past their sell-by
date mish approached one and a half
minutes mr. president mr. president all
too often we week has in the case of our
reaction to the court judgment on
Singapore or the failure of
multilateralism the fact is we've now
seen a new development in globalization
economic planning by foreign powers
dumping hostile investments the
acquisition of strategic companies
strict rules on our companies operating
abroad unfair competition and the lack
of reciprocity there was no agreement
yesterday in the trial log on dumping I
don't think this is a failure because we
need to have a clear
political message especially as regards
the burden of proof Europe needs to
protect itself without lapsing into
protectionism that's a clear message our
treaty requires us to be extremely
cautious in terms of our legal
obligations hence the uncertainty the
ambitious draft regulation will at least
save us walking on our heads we've lost
time and in reality we're losing jobs
we're losing know-how and technological
advancement as a result of country
that's organizing its investments and
private and public companies we're not
against foreign investment but we're
against strange investment we need to
make sure that we don't end up with
future apples or iPhones assembled
entirely in China now see one minute mr.
astonish F thank you madam chair and
thank you president Juncker for your
speech I know you are a deeply convinced
European and in your sixth scenario I
don't see Europe which is divided or
several speed Europe which is very
positive but at the same time you know
that people are tired of words and
promises and it's time for action from
the Commission as well and the strongest
tool which you possess is a commission
is the project the draft of your budget
for the next multi-annual financial
framework we should stop thinking how to
reduce the European budget ballot but
look for own resources we should really
focus on political priorities and the
major priority is how to move from
Europe of divergence inequalities
towards Europe of convergence and strong
economic growth and social justice I
expected frankly speaking stronger
social dimension we really need a
European social action plan today in
order to regain trust thank you very
much
one and a half minutes mr. Gonzalez
pants
Vientos parabola Senor well favorable
winds that's true mr. young we've left
behind the euro crisis and now we've got
to also move this positive atmosphere on
to social protection and works I liked
what you said about the rule of law and
equality sometimes it seems in Europe
that is more important to us to solve
the financial crisis than the political
and social crisis that we face here we
talked about brexit as if it were just
you know going to be another free trade
association actually starting from this
it isn't just about European Union
defending the idea of Europe what we've
got to do after brexit we have to see
that the will in fact be do different
Europe's inside our continent I share
your points of view when it comes to the
role of courts as regard the European
Court and national courts this is in
fact one of the very finding reasons of
the European Union there are countries
that are attacking the separation of
power and that's what's happening in a
region in fact in my country where
nationalism is not attacking the
Constitution nationalism is expanding
just like a virus the constitution of
each of Member State is in fact the
building blocks of the European Union
the unity of my country is also the
unity of the European Union this is why
the European Commission has also got and
I share this responsibility to defend
the Constitution's of all of the Member
States and to defend the unity of the
Member States and the rule of law is
born out of the individual right but it
grows and developed if you follow the
law and the courts thank you
thank you one minute madam Tama
thank you very much I'm very
disappointed I have to say first of all
your last chance saloon hasn't really
worked you're not giving us a battle
plan for the end of the mandate you're
giving us a strange way ahead strange
route ahead for the future there are a
certain number of priorities that we
could go along with social tax and
freedom but these are all words moving
from words to deeds as you said this
morning we need a serious budget and
that's my second disappointment you're
saying you want to break out of the
straitjacket that exists now but what
about this 20% ceiling nothing definite
about that own resources nothing about
that multinational taxes nothing there
either
fiscal justice is something that we
really need to focus on and that hasn't
happened so I'm very disappointed as
well about economic and monetary
democracy there are new prerogatives
that we want what we need is to ensure
that we can choose economic ways forward
and break out of austerity but you
haven't given us the chance to do that
thank you madam Gardini one minute
please cigarette tip therapist Thanks
Madam President mr. president you've set
out a model for the future of Europe and
I can share a lot of the things you say
starting with the protection of Europe's
strategic interest some analysts think
that this is the most important
geopolitical aspect of your whole speech
I want to say something about the reform
of the Treaty of Dublin that's a
priority for our group and it's
unavoidable if we want to back European
industry starting we
small and medium enterprises youth
unemployment but let me just say one
question in my brief remaining time
Europe needs more democracy you've said
but you didn't say anything about that
this assembly directly elected elected
by our citizens it doesn't have a
legislative initiative rights don't you
think that should be on the agenda we
need to get the wind in our sails as
you've said and we can do that if
citizens really see it that they at the
heart of everything we do in Europe
thank you president thank you one minute
madam Garcia Perez Gracia
thank you miss madam president for years
now Europe has stopped being part and
parcel of our dreams and the idea of a
project which is equality opportunities
has become something altogether
different precarious jobs austerity
economic crisis today those of us who
believe in the European project will
agree that there are grounds for concern
that we need to move ahead with new
policies for the European Union the
European social pillar must be a
priority it's simply not possible for a
21st century Europe to continue to have
a working class that lives below the
poverty line let's talk about the fight
against climate change let's face up to
the fight against terrorism asylum and
immigration policy these are of
fundamental importance thank you mr.
young confirm mentioning the rule of law
Europe is a project based on democracy
therefore it's fundamental that we
guarantee a respectful cut the
constitutional order of each and every
member state there's no time to be
wasted we need to get on with it and
tackle these changes diversity dialogue
respect cohesion this is what defines
Europe let's not allow anything or
anybody changes this thank you
one minute mr. sugar a most welcome with
emphasis you placed on the idea of
Europe the community of values mr.
Rinker that the need to ensure freedom
equality and rule of law all over the
you said that we there would no be
second-class citizens anymore in our
integration project still European
citizens belonging to national adopt
honest or language minorities can be
treated very differently depending on
where they live only last week in
Romania Hungarian minority language
catholic high school of tubular ceased
to exist because the systematic
harassment of various authorities were
hundreds of minority language speaking
children were in security until the last
moment about whether they would be able
to attend their school again what do the
parents of these children who are
interrogated by the Romanian
anti-corruption agency for enrolling
their children in the school feel from
the rule of law that the U is supposed
to guarantee them this still has a long
way to go to ensure its values and
prevent discriminative practices more
than 60 million citizens expect
acknowledgement of their existence by
the institutions thank you mr. Biden
holes are one minute 15 really I'm Katie
Kenny at the moment we're in a curious
situation in Europe we've got Trump and
got brexit but thanks to that people are
more positive about the EU but it's not
all good we're a long way from having
solved the migration issue and the
improvement that in the economy that you
have mentioned isn't a benefiting
everybody parts of Austria for example
aren't seeing that and there's also more
of a disparity now between east and west
you know I'm happy to see mr. timmermans
here taking a very clean clear line the
COS Commission is the custodian of the
treaties and has to guarantee the
fundamental rights as a result but is
this openness to dialogue that I'm not
seeing in those who
trying to benefit at the expense of
Brussels how to act against that well
Brussels has to be better more
democratic and act in a more social way
and I think you've given us a good basis
for that madam phalion one minute
thank you president congratulations for
your strong messages in your State of
the Union today for the first time in
years or citizens show growing faith in
the you and it's direction their
confidence is just a fine proof that the
EU remains where they put their hopes
and where they want to live and prosper
for all these we are ibly obliged to
keep our word and deliver on what you
have promised some will say we'll need
more ambition I say we need stability
consolidation and proper implementation
of your policies we need to defend our
values to make sure our citizens can
fully benefit from their rights and
freedoms and that the competitiveness of
our companies is both defended and
supported yet the engine of our internal
market is not fairness but competition
and it has to be a real one you can't
send people home saying go compete in
your own country while we protect our
national markets because the internal
market it's not the sum of national
markets the State of the Union should
also be about how we can offer more
Europe for everyone thank you thank you
madam Moscow one minute great simplicity
thank you madam president president
Juncker
trade policy is one of those powerful
instruments we have and although
obviously it can't sort out everything
it needs to be continually updated and
improved to meet global challenges which
are constantly in flux
I was listening carefully to what you
were saying particularly about
transparency but I think we should
really stress three points first of all
trade is still genuine the European
policy open Democratic without
sacrificing the need for us to
together that's why the union needs to
be ever more closely involved in all
phases of the process and not simply
Parliament's our sense at the end of an
agreement being reached secondly
sustainable development if the chapters
are not going to be effective they need
to be binding
I'm glad the Commission's done what it's
done but it needs to continue thinking
bring it into real practice and
providing sufficient money and
Parliament's willing to help on that
thirdly it's vital because opening up in
terms of trade is based on fairness and
reciprocity and we can't have these
waivers depending on who the partner is
that will threaten our whole economic
system thank you madam president mr.
Rochelle one minute
madam vice president
mr. Janka my dear president first of all
my compliments to you for today's speech
thank you I think this gives a new
Philip to us it encouraged all of us who
- all of us who love Europe like mr.
Yonker now there is a challenge which is
not one of your immediate concerns at
least not those we heard today this year
[Music]
there was a wave of forest fires in
Portugal with tragic consequences
they've been floods all over Europe
including recently impotant but tragic
consequence at last year there were
earthquakes in Italy they've also been
earthquakes in Greece and with climate
change are going to be a lot of these
catastrophes would it not be turned to
create a year European civil protection
force now this of course ties in with
internal security that have missions in
the Mediterranean rescue at sea this
kind of thing but when this kind of
catastrophe supervenes we should get out
there help national forces to mitigate
the consequences of such catastrophe so
I think it's high time to create a
European civil protection force and it
would be the Emperor of what could
eventually become a real European army
thank you
mr. Pullman one minute
Yonkers yob president Janka you've given
a speech which meets up to your own
expectations
it was sober and we've heard that the
east we needs the West but also vice
versa
and I think the same goes for north and
south as well I've never been quite as
revolted as the time when I had to read
in the German papers saying if you want
coal Seles Corfu I mean this was quoted
from stupid politicians and I'm very
glad that you never got dragged into
that debate but you stood up to it I
know that that's not the level at which
you operate but we can't say that
economic policy in Europe depends on
who's in government where whether
there's a Greek haircut is a technical
issue it shouldn't depend on whether or
not your political allies are in
government in one country or not we need
a policy that can help the south to
develop but we need the south in this
very difficult to period the world's
going through mr. kovachev one minute
Nagaraja priscilla tell professor on
thank you madam president
I'm pleased with what you've told us mr.
president now we need to achieve the
goals that you've said we need to be
effective in the European Union because
it'll be our fault if the European Union
is ineffective next year the EU needs to
demonstrate that the promise is to keep
its citizens safe going to be met we
should focus therefore on things like
cyber security control of our external
borders and solidarity to be shown with
states where there are a large number of
migrants entering I like the idea of a
cybersecurity agency mr. president we
also need to continue to help Europe
recover economically and maintain its
social standards and its public health
standards also we need to help those
sectors where the crisis as his hardest
and we shouldn't allow any part of the
European Union to be neglected I'm glad
that you're thinking about we not have a
two-speed Europe that's the most
important thing Thank You mr. Boston our
one minute thank you madam president
don't appreciate int a president
jean-claude Juncker I would like to
thank you today for the courage the
vision and the wisdom of your speech but
moreover for the force to oppose those
who favor eyes the division of Europe
and the double standards in the project
of Europe with several speeds on behalf
of the Romanian delegation on behalf of
my political group and on behalf of my
country I share your vision and I commit
myself to supporting you if I analyze
your speech Europe can be an important
player in matters of security only if we
are united
only if we speak on one voice and only
if there is complete trust among
if we look at the cohesion policy it is
fundamental to implement the principle
of solidarity and to reduce all these
priorities and this is why I would like
you to give attention to come to the
continuation of this fundamental
instrument of the Union Union and
solidarity means that there are no
double standards in cases of enhanced
cooperation that schengen cannot be
refused when there are conditions which
are fulfilled and that the CBM cannot be
continued unless it is necessary and the
quality of food is the same for all
Europeans Thank You mr. Needham our one
minute please
Thank You Madame and thank you mr.
president for your speech it is good to
remind us about how things have changed
since last year just to remind all of us
grosses up unemployment down employment
up stable financial sector improved
fiscal policy and this is just economy
you mentioned more you can say these are
just numbers these are not just numbers
this means that life for people in
Europe is better and this is what people
expect from us also as you know from
your past the good time is exactly the
time where people are making a lot of
mistakes and you urge us to not make
mistakes in the school time and instead
to go to many good things and I agree
and I appreciated it one of the
obstacles that I want to stress is still
missing Trust trust among politicians
trust among people trust among countries
I hope that in next speech you will
remind us that this has improved this is
very important and also at the end of
your speeches you mentioned that we
shouldn't be over cautious this is
exactly the way how to make the mistakes
and to miss the opportunities I hope we
will not miss them thank you very much
thank you one minute madam Van Brunt
thank you all for seaters camisa
committee four-seater yonkers thank you
very much mr. president of the
Commission your speech was optimistic
perhaps not fully fledged optimism was
expressed but the general turn was
optimistic and it's something I think we
can support with a fair degree of
enthusiasm transparency climate
protection the climate of Industry
ensuring that there's more democracy we
completely agree however we were still
left feeling that there could have been
we want a triple-a on social issues
three years issue three is discussion on
social dumping and no results look we
need to ensure that everybody in Europe
obtain work in the same conditions and
receive the same salary there's got to
be proper Social Security in Shanthi
European legislation and and will be
measured on our action particular on
social action thank you thank you madam
else cook one minute please
futon man had a commercial madam
president mr. president of the
Commission thank you for what you've
told us this morning
mr. Juncker and thank you for having
talked about better standards for the
labor market these better standards will
be crucial for the whole of the EU we
need to take positive measures here
nothing divides us more than social
dumping which means that workers are set
against workers and sell their labor as
cheaply as possible that's a disgrace
for Europe and there are many of us who
are focusing our hopes on you to improve
the situation we need to have some kind
of overseeing Authority but also
legislation a directive and legislation
on the social market that can't be done
the labor
sorry that can't be done from outside we
need a social protocol thank you poor
Pierre got to be a mom as you said on
the eurozone we think you need to
respect countries which don't want to
take part such as my own that needs to
be respected their decision thank you
president thanks we now move to catch
the eye and I will disappoint more
people than I will please
so with that remark I will try and give
the floor to as many as possible but
probably around 9 colleagues so
immediately for one minute and very
strictly please Madame spear Aki
thank you madam president president
Janka the citizens are waiting for us
directly to show we don't like populism
and extremism in Europe we need to come
up with rational correct solutions we
can't
it seems provide wellbeing for everybody
we need to make sure however that we
encourage our citizens and reward as
many of them as we can we need to keep
Europe safe from terrorism and we need
to have a European information service
which will help that goal we have large
numbers of migrants and member states
need to look to their own
responsibilities here and need to be
sanctioned if they don't the Greeks and
the Italians are facing the brunt of
this crisis mr. president and we need to
make sure that cuts in the budget for
things like research don't hamper the
situation still further Thank You senior
appreciat madam president president
Yocum in the in your home straight
you've given us your longer speech with
the most intentions we want actual
solutions that legal ways in not just
this blue card for selective immigration
we want humanitarian visas
as decent jobs for young people fight
against poverty particularly child
poverty fight against inequality
tackling fraud and tax havens we've seen
all of this and the Panama committee all
but a puppet did they
it's not about rule of law the ignoring
court rulings is being in breach of the
law it's a crime and that can happen in
Hungary in Poland and Catalonia anyway
it's a negation of Europe we're about
the rule of law
thank you one minute mr. Mariusz thank
you madam president
president Younker you're five scenarios
to change in the European Union in their
put forward a sixth one which where we
continue with the same policies the same
institutions and the same balances that
existed before a German dominated Europe
austerity and the stability pact
it's the anti-democratic eurozone the
uncontrolled euro groove running the
European and the European Central Bank
it's Bangkok recei and the a series of
people-friendly measures are being
brought in outsourcing and we can see
Europe's industrial base being
undermined and European salaries being
reduced so Europe of unemployment and
marginalization of young people and this
of course has been worsened by a million
migrants and illegal migrants what we
need to do is combat unemployment and
poverty and we can't do it by failing to
deal with the huge migrant flows which
are existing at the moment we need to do
something to protect the European family
thank you they only be barber and DCAM
miss Bilbao bernard iike senior young
care come up with it mr. Juncker as you
can see here my party the pnv organised
that or celebrated
the national birthday in 1932 saying
pass country Europe so I liked a lot of
proposals but what about women who
suffer inequality in violence
we need need proper support for plans
and we need to protect and empower
people we want a social Europe that's
open refuge united against terrorism
more industry support for real economy
economic and political capacity the
single energy and digital market we are
victims of the short sessom of member
states democratic values the rights are
variably including national minorities
that do exist and as in Catalonia
instead of recognizing that reality you
prefer to just stifle everything without
political action that we have a European
problem
the intergroup on minorities in this
parliament has called for dialogue
democracy cannot be imposed but nobody
should hinder it either nobody should
hinder a political solution to the
problem I'm not even there City
Quixote's mister city Quixote's Thank
You mr. president
the Union today needs to remain stable
and at the surface of its citizens we
need to make sure that there are plans
to increase unemployment and improve
labor conditions particularly in those
countries which are living under
memoranda but you're just offering the
same thing again keeping the regional
imbalances and unfairness is in place
mr. president we still have poverty
pockets in Europe what we need to do is
not submit money willy-nilly in the
defense fund we need to make sure that
there's real economic growth on Europe
we need to make sure that there be some
proper way of dealing with the refugees
not simply some agreement put together
with Turkey we in the left want to see a
different kind of Europe getting rid of
poverty and inequality we need more
public expenditure if we are going to
create decent jobs we need a social
Europe a Europe of solidarity and peace
we need a Europe in the interest of its
citizens thank you there's a lunatic
thank you
call me Soames president president of
the Commission the Greens slogan about
us remain critical but remain we want to
make a environmentally sustainable union
so that citizens can believe in it again
cosmetic changes are simply not enough
you've made a few interesting
suggestions but when it comes to trade
it's still the interests of the big
companies that are being put to the fore
the balance is not as it should be in a
democracy what we want and what we need
are fair trade agreements otherwise
there's no point in talking about why
refugees flee their homes what you said
about the rule of law was good to hear
and I also is pleased to hear you say
that you together with the European
Parliament will be looking at the
funding of European parties and
foundations and to change that funding
so that right-wing extremists can't fill
their coffers in order to knock back the
European principals but it's not enough
to describe the State of the Union we
have to change the imbalance and make
the EU credible again for all EU
citizens there's more of a
thank you very much mr. Uecker in your
position I think it's a very good idea
to watch television every now and then
if you do so these days you can see
really good news from Syria and from
Iraq the wars are almost over rebuilding
has begun refugees are returning home
don't you think and please answer this
question don't you think that it's high
time to fundamentally we consider the
relocation and resettlement quota idea
of the European Union stop bashing
Hungary stop preaching us about
solidarity and talk about solidarity to
those strong healthy young Syrian and
other men who should go home
and rebuild their countries that is
solidarity with those nations
thank you very much Maria Christopher Oh
mr. Christopher oh the bravery Thank You
president I welcome the speech of the
president of the Commission and I'm
particularly pleased that he focused on
the core values of the European Union we
need to look at freedom the rule of law
and equality mr. president that is what
Europe is based on and that's what the
basis for a strong Europe giving
well-being to its citizens and we
shouldn't have agreements with countries
like Turkey who don't share our European
values European citizens should feel
proud when they take part in the
freedoms which Europe has given them
and don't forget we couldn't deal with
countries which don't simply fail to
respect human rights at home but have
seized territory in my own country it's
important that we remember this and
don't simply allow the customs union to
continue in the way that it is at the
moment we have values in Europe and we
need to protect them together mr.
president thank you well it costs that
miss Costa Presidente Yunker gracias
Thank You mr. president president Janka
thank you for what you said and you're
genuinely European vision it's something
which could put the wind in the sails of
Europe again and help young citizens
particularly young British citizens are
going to be suffering the impact of
BRICS is when we need to look at
sustainable development defense foreign
policy more justice we can play a role
in the world and that can only be
guaranteed by more Europe free fair
United United also in terms of the
priorities that it has and the values
which it shares if we're going to do
that we need to have a cultural and
educational dimension of the European
project they need to be leading elements
on thirty years on from the beginning of
Erasmus let me ask you whether we can't
think about doubling the number of young
people who are eligible that's still
only 5% of young Europeans that would of
course recall a doubling of its budget
the European cultural heritage during
year which you mentioned that's going to
begin in Milan in December along with
our new cultural diplomacy most
mogherini and commissioned elaborate
issue behind that that's a tremendous
opportunity for us to share and
disseminate our values and promote
intercultural dialogue and developing
Europe's social cohesion creating
quality jobs thank you very much this
maker
thank you for sister Minnie Oh Thank You
mr. president
mr. Janka
well we keep on talking about a
democratic Europe about recovering their
hearts and minds of our citizens the
trust of citizens and the fact of matter
is any piece we are close to our
citizens after all that's how democracy
begins and works and I have to say to
our group of what the Catalan colleagues
said last week hundreds of thousands of
Catalans
filled the streets of Barcelona with
color and I think we needed to develop
their European future and we've got to
do that democratically and we know full
well that the problems between positive
Madrid have gone to court and that civil
servants have been given orders to
boycott the referendum there has been
intimidation in the media and elsewhere
you're aware of that and as a Fleming we
can't accept that want a Europe as
citizens and we want the democracy to
flourish and be respected this mystical
Index last speaker in Katzie I thank you
president president Janka the situation
in Europe isn't really as you described
it workers look at the Union as
something which is reducing their wages
and rights pensioners see nothing but
further cuts in their pensions
unemployed people see the carrot plus in
terms of investment but the stick of the
weakening of legal protection and threat
of job losses your comments and what mr.
macro said recently show that you're
violating democracy particularly in my
own country you're ignoring the wishes
of the Greek people expressed in 2015
and your Commissioner has
that the Greeks trying to end austerity
in their own country as a scandal this
is simply not fair we need to work
together in terms of the industry and
the environment but we need a Europe of
peace not simply a Europe of war and
aggression Thank You bene grazie a tutti
thanks very much to all members who took
part in the debate I now turn to
jean-claude Juncker president of the
Commission to reply to the comments
which have been made
jean-claude go ahead Monsieur president
madam mr. president ladies and gentlemen
colleagues I spoke I believe for more
than an hour there was no mean feat for
you it was even more difficult for me
because I have a rather painful sciatica
I have to rest up I'm afraid so I won't
be able to answer you in great detail
but what I will say is as follows the
Commission where it's already taken
initiatives it will continue to work
towards making legislation for example
on social issues the council and the
Parliament have seen a whole range of
initiatives submitted to them and I
don't need to list them here because
those texts have been forwarded to you
so it's not the Commission if you like
that is responsible for the seconding of
workers directives not having been
reviewed yet
and indeed I think the same would apply
to a number of other proposals
you would do well to read the letter of
intention that mr. Timmons and I have
sent to the Parliament as president over
a number of pages we described in detail
the Commission's intentions and we would
like to involve the Parliament and the
council very closely in the work that
will be done between now and the 24th of
October and after that that being a date
when the work program for the Commission
is adopted and I hope that we'll be able
to work together ha moment harmoniously
and I hope that we'll wrap up the year
with a joint declaration on the work of
the three presidents of the three
institutions and I apologize for having
to leave now
[Applause]
gratz is imploded the possible thank you
jean-claude we can send the doctor
around if you like to and take care of
you so that you can always be at full
strength than answer all of the
questions that we have those would like
to thank vice president mogherini for
the extreme endurance that she showed in
plenary yesterday now the final round of
speeches ladies and gentlemen and the
first speaker in mr. Cena do not Thank
You president I listened to what you
said mr. young car very carefully and it
sounded as if you pranic promising
paradise to us in Europe but if you look
at what the present European Commission
has done is produced unemployment
poverty migration and it's failed to
address any of these problems as well as
the possible entry of Islamist
terrorists into Europe we need to have a
more people centered approach to Europe
people are not happy with the way things
are going we're fed up with the
disastrous results of your globalized
policies we have democratically elected
governments in Poland and Hungary and
they are given in the interests of their
people the Greeks the poles the hungry
Hungarians including the Brits who voted
to leave the European Union don't want
more or less Europe they wants a more
democratic Europe a safer Europe one
that respects national sovereignty and
respects other member states Thank You
[Applause]
mr. Dekker
for sitter recessed dr. Baker Hart Smith
mr. president some seem to be saying
that things are getting better in the
European Union they're closing their
eyes or living in never-never land is
the mr. countries are sending large
numbers of people to our shores and
every day met or women and children are
raped by immigrants in our cities by
immigrants of Islamic origin there's no
safety of security European Union and
this parmitt is full of bleeding hearts
use still closing your eyes to the
dangers of Islam and you're spending
millions for the coast guard and
defending our borders and it's not
enough there's a problem debt is a
problem of unemployment and the European
Union is losing market share
internationally so things aren't going
great in the European Union in the
interim the UK has taken to a lifeboat
and left at the Titanic Eastern
countries are engaging in and countries
near us are engaging in all sorts of
dictatorial acts and witch hunts social
failure economic failure security feed
mr. Juncker has done a runner
so really stop with this electoral
propaganda and just stop this project
which has just been a failure
mr. pack says for a permanent campus all
in my burrito Parliament our Oslo Thank
You president since the after the Second
World War the British MP Leon Emery
criticized the British government
and said that mr. Chamberlain had
crumbled now you have spent far too long
here go get out he said to Chamberlain I
don't want to say the same thing to mr.
Yunker but I would just remind him of it
those who had tried to teach lessons to
the countries of Eastern Europe should
stop now
I myself am not much of a seaman but I
don't think one can rely on the winds to
reach top speed oh you don't deserve mr.
Lueck in today's debate a president we
didn't hear any self-criticism about the
impact of austerity policies imposed on
ordinary people and there's no way you
can move forward a new social project
secondly we've heard a lot about
democracy but I think that the
combination of a single president in the
Commission and the council we don't know
who's got our points this person and
transforming the stability pact into a
European Monetary Fund when we know how
the IMF works the International Monetary
Fund is a very worrying development
because we're gonna see simultaneous
centralization of power and stricter
oversight of Member States budgets so
it'll be more austerity there's nothing
good to come from that quarter and the
idea of that being a more democratic
Europe is simply not correct Thank You
mr. hofstadt just say the most important
things that we ourself confuse our
leaders at a European level we can chose
our national leaders that's the most
important point
and I hope that the GUI will support the
idea of transnational list which will
express this dream will have and the
ability to decide who lazier Oh only two
conclusions president mr. de Graaff says
it goes back way the European you and I
think it goes back with the populist and
the nationalist in the European Union it
makes a he makes a mistake problems are
in his movement for the moment not with
the European Union he's even saying that
yeah no there is no increase for example
in the number of jobs well everybody
knows that there is an increase in the
numbers of jobs in European and my
second conclusion mr. Thomas is that is
hopefully you have seen here in the
center of this house a broad support for
the program ambitious program that mr.
Juncker has presented and you have to
take that on board and use that as a
tool to words or Member States and to
the council so that from their side
there will be also the same ambitious
and support for that ambitious program
thank you burn or evil in a good go mr.
LaHood cool
well I won't hide the fact that I'm a
little bit surprised that President
Juncker didn't say much in terms of the
conclusions to be drawn from brexit I
mean I think that brexit is a great loss
to the Union and if I did think that I
would expect the President to tell us
what he'd done to balance out breaks it
but on the other hand he didn't say that
it's good and there's a success I don't
think it's a success I think it's a
failure
now mr. younger has suggest said he's
suggested a number of scenarios and that
there's been a discussion and a debate
what debate a debate is when you don't
know the end conclusion that we already
have a conclusion now we've got a fait
accompli
these conclusions are just more of the
same old same old
more Europe from all Europe inside this
solution are we really being treated
seriously when you tell us that is this
really a debate a debate means putting
forward arguments and replying to
arguments just recall the expressions
used to describe those who are of a
different point of view today we heard
idiots virus viruses we heard extremists
we even heard them being accused of
taking money for their views is that as
discussion if it carries on like that we
all know where we're going to end up
more Europe one president one Minister
to do this
everyone's been saying let's keep going
forwards no let's not keep going
forwards let's look at what's happening
somebody's quite rightly said that it's
not true that breaking rules only
applies to their mothers it happens here
too it happens within the EU rules are
criminally contravened by institutions
of the EU including the European
Commission which also itself breaks
rules people are also not addicted to a
double standard tip there are parties
and institutions that are allowed to do
whatever they like and get away with it
scot-free and then there are weaker
players in this game who aren't allowed
to do much at all let's clean up our own
put our own house in order first let's
begin with the renovation so the
Commission let's begin by getting the
Commission's house in order and then we
can start thinking of building wonderful
other institutions but let's first of
all cure the illness that is raging in
the European institutions at the moment
and as quickly as possible please
these sake based on the battery given
the importance of this debate colleagues
and that we have been flexible in terms
of speaking time in the debate
theoretically the Greens have used up
all of their available time but if scar
can or mr. Lambrix want to say something
for one minute I'll give them the floor
but we shall have fun mini decathletes
angeles i was leading up to date of how
it was looking my cat that's very kind
of you president mister panetta
momentous state around that's no bad
thing mister Timmerman's i've listened
to what your boss has to say i know what
he wants to do he's he's saying about
that there'll be a europe with no
second-class citizens right but today
some of our citizens have to keep on
eating products which you don't want to
ban because of better regulation there
are high rises on fire there all would
that have been a fire like in the UK
because we don't want to do anything
about anti [ __ ] of all fire retardants
and national stands are the good enough
so simply quite simply I would ask the
Commission to make a gesture and heed
the words of your boss thank you now
Gianni pittella
for the SMD group Thank You president I
believe that a Europe which works in the
interest of its citizens zero but that
doesn't work properly runs counter to
those interests and simply increases
citizens disinfection let's be honest
there are forces in Europe and in this
house which are working so that Europe
doesn't work properly so as to gain from
this back home its exact opposite of
what we want we want a visionary project
for Europe a Europe that works and
responds to the problems of its citizens
we want a parliament that has
legislative powers please
what kind of parliament in the world
doesn't have the possibility of
proposing legislation there's no
Parliament in the world like this
apart from the European Parliament that
would help citizens
would help democracy if that were to be
the case secondly transnational
agreements I am happy to work with the
EPP as far as transnational lists are
concerned it's a new form for European
democracy a president of the Commission
directly elected by the citizens and the
President of the Council the same two
hats principle that's a good idea in
this case but without being voted on by
the people we have to be careful that
needs the people's participation needs
to be guaranteed a kind of European
federal system in terms of the economy a
European federal bank all of this needs
to be hedged about with European culture
because European culture is what holds
Europe together it's a dream it's
something we want but also a political
program for us it's the Utopia but a
possible utopia Thank You mr. Weber
surgical ex ladies and gentlemen the
debate today showed that shanty Blanca
can count on the support of the European
Parliament for this program and we
showed political diversity that's the
nature of a parliament I only want to
react on three points one is about the
debate on legal migration everybody is
in favor of said high-skilled workers
who can arrive in Europe this blue card
there's no debate about this but we have
to be frank
do we really think that more legal
migration to the European Union bill
solves the illegal migration problem
dear friends how many Africans do we
invite to a map to Europe to come do we
really think that this will solves a
problem I think on behalf of my group
that first of all we have to have in
mind the millions of young Europeans who
have at the moment no chops and we
cannot say to send we open the door for
more legal migration mentes themself
have no chops dear friends the second
point about the transnational list
dear friends everybody wants to
strengthen the European democracy and I
have to to be clear to chancla Juncker
European DPP is not in favor on this
transnational list because we are not
convinced G we are not convinced on the
main on the main argument because yes
European Parliament is more than 27
individual votes it's clear but sorry
the overwhelming majority of all the
members of sister up in Parliament shows
everyday that we are not only national
any piece we are doing today a
transnational shop we are thinking in
the interest of all of us and that's why
there is not an additional list
necessary for this I am from Germany
I cannot elect in my constituency in
Bavaria Angela Merkel because we have
only regional lists in Germany so that
works even in Germany then it also can
work in Europe and finally on the social
Union so journey journey social Union
first of all very seriously when we talk
about climate change socialists are in
favor the fight against climate change
Greens EPP when we talk about trade then
we have a good understanding that we are
in favor of trading when we talk about
the social Union then please allow that
other other groups are also defending
the social principles in this European
social policy is not occupied by the
Socialists frankly speaking it is an
issue for all of us for all of us and
when you and when you are and when you
are asking us as EPP to look about the
social Union then your friends look
first of all to the reality in the
countries where the Socialists govern or
governs France for example or Italy we
have a big problem on unemployment in a
lot of countries where EPP is governing
in Germany and in our land we have a
good economic situation that's why we
are working on social Union and you are
only speaking on social Union thanks so
much
[Applause]
la la discusión a sous la stat that
brings the debate on the State of the
Union
[Music]
ladies that brings the debate on the
State of the Union to a close but the
debate on the future of Europe is open
Parliament I think will be at the heart
of all of these initiatives if President
yonkers calling for a more democratic
Europe we are the concrete
representation of Europe at its most
democratic a la deuda on Monday the 11th
various decisions were